في استديو نورنا من فريق شاهد يوسف زين
الدين يوسف يسعد صباحك اهلا يسعد صباحكم
رمضان واعمال رمضان عم نحكي عن اربعين عمل
واكثر راح نشوفهم برمضان على منصه شاهد
اليوم جبنا جزء منهم وبالايام القادمه ان
شاء الله بنكمل ونحكي
برمضان طيب نبدا باول باول الاعمال
الدراميه
الخاص لجعفر العمده لمحمد رمضان محمد
رمضان رح يطلع بهذا المسلسل الشخص او جعفر
العمده اللي هو باسمه يعني راح يكون جعفر
العمده متزوج ثلاث سيدات القدر بيخليه انه
يتلاقى بالسيده الرابعه شو السبب اللي
حيخليه يتزوج بالسيده الرابعه راح نشوف
هالسيدات كيف علاقات الحب بيناتهم كيف
المشاكسات بيناتهم الحمامه موجوده
فالمسلسل كله يعني فيه قالب درامي كوميدي
ايضا فيه جزء من الاكشن
احكيلكم عن هذا المسلسل ليه حلو لانه كمان
هو التعاون الرابع راح يكون بين محمد سامي
ومحمد رمضان شفناهم طبعا
طبعا
الاول والثاني حقق نجاح باهر جماهيريه
كبيره شو رح نستنى من للموت ثلاثه للموت
ثلاثه من المسلسلات اللي مكمله معنا
زي ما حكيتي بالجزء الثالث على ثلاث سنوات
متتاليه اللي حضروا الجزء الثاني توقع
وفاه سحر وريم ولكن راح نكتشف انهم ما
ماتوا انتقلوا لتونس وراح تبدا الاعمال او
تبدا الخطه الدراميه بتونس راح نشوف راح
يبداوا حياه جديده ولكن القدر ما رح
يخليهم بحالهم والماضي بدي يعني اخص انه
ما رح اخليهم بحالهم راح نشوف وجوه جديده
طلعت معنا
احنا خلصنا من الموت كتب لنا حياه ثانيه
بالنسبه للكل
[موسيقى]
هلا هون سحروا ريم اللي انا بعرفهم انا مش
سحر انا سمر
ومحسوب تكرين
تجاره اسلحه تبريد اموال تزوير عمله
[موسيقى]
شو اسمك سمر شكل راح نتسلى كتير يا
ننتقل يعني ممثلين جداد راح يدخلوا على
هذا الجزء مسلسل كامل العدد كامل العدد
راح نحضره حصري فقط على شاهد يعني ما رح
نقدر نشوفه على اي قناه اخرى فقط على شهر
15 حلقه طبعا للنجمه دينا الشربيني شاركها
بالبطوله شريف سلامه وطبعا في ظهور خاص لا
القديره اسعاد يونس طبعا راح يكون فيه جو
كوميدي درامي ايضا راح نشوف كل واحد من
هالشخصيات عنده سر رح يبداوا يتلاقوا مع
بعض رح يصير في قصه حب ولكن كل واحد مخبي
على الثاني سر ليه مخبي هذا السر خايف
ممكن انه العلاقه ما تكمل طب نشوف مقطع
يلا
كلميني على المشروع عندنا مزرعه صغيره كده
طبيعيه واعشاب
اللي عملناه مش معقول اروح عيد ميلاد
بلبله وانا وش منفخ ووارم مش احترام
لاجدادك تشقط في المعابد يا احمد هو مش اي
واحده
تعملي فيها فر
حاسس حالي بالافلام
[موسيقى]
وعدني ما تتركني
وبعد واخيرا من هو ولدنا بس جزء ثاني
هالمره
الجزء الاول نجاح كثير كبير الرمضان
الماضي طبعا القصه كانت بين انه تم تبديل
ولدين الولد الغني والولد الفقير وتم
تبديلهم بالمستشفى من هم اطفال ولكن عرفوا
هذا الموضوع لما كبروا فحنرجع نشوف مع بعض
كيف كملوا حياتهم بعد ما تم تبديلهم يعني
تخيلي انت من حياه فقيره لغنيه والغني رح
يرجع لحياه فقيره طبعا راح يكون في صراعات
بين الولدين
وعلى حسب الاسم المسلسل من هو ولدنا يعني
انه مين ابن مين وفيه كتير بس ولكن مسلسل
كوميدي بامتياز خلينا نشوف يلا
يا ولد نزل الشنطه
سندريلا بطلها شاب ضرب معاه الضربه لقى
نفسها من قاع الفقر لقمه الثراء
[موسيقى]
سعودي
يعني اكيد هيك حبسنا المشاهدين لرمضان
رمضان رمضان على الابواب هذا جزء فقط بحب
احكي لكم كل الاربعين من اربعين من
الاربعين عنا
يعني ان شاء الله اكيد
طبعا اذهبوا الى تطبيق شاهد
وبالتاكيد سيكون هناك المزيد من المسلسلات
يوسف